foreign
my name is Spencer Clays and I
specialize in deep cleaning and removing
layers of moss off of roofs
the area that you live in in the climate
definitely plays a huge factor in into
the amount of moss that goes on roofs
up here in the Pacific Northwest we have
a lot of moss because there's a lot of
rain there's not a lot of sunlight and
there's a lot of trees and stuff that
provide all that material for the stuff
to grow on
foreign
there's probably hundreds of thousands
of species but generally if it's green
or black or something living up there it
needs to be removed
so here this gutter guard sponge was
completely grown in compacted with mold
Moss so we need to get it out put in
some new gutter guards so that the
gutters could be flowing and working as
they should
the purpose of the gutter guard is to
keep stuff out of the gutters this
sponge got so grown in compacted and
stuff that we needed to remove it and
put in new gutter guards
a mosque can get up in between any crack
or crevice that you have up on the roof
and the gutters it either grows bigger
and bigger and bigger and the water can
get up in there as well too or in the
winter too when it freezes it can freeze
and expand you know really break that
seal that your house or roof typically
has
so Moss really loves growing especially
on Roos that have a lower pitch when it
has a higher pitch it has a harder time
grabbing onto a hold of the roof but if
it's a lower pitch it's a lot less steep
there can be quite a bit more Moss
because it's it has a lot easier time of
getting in between the cracks there
and generally you're going to see a lot
more moss growth on the Northern side
you know when there's where there's lack
of sunlight so that's that's really one
of the biggest factors
Moss has the easiest time of growing in
between asphalt shingle roofs the moths
can really get up in there grow expand
and break the seal of the shingle for
the roof and water can get up in there
more Moss organic material and it can
cause mold and water can get up in there
and damage the roof
I'll generally start any cleaning
process with the leaf blower and the
brush getting all that organic material
off before I start treating it
so when you see like this level of moss
that come up on a roof there's almost no
way around you got to get that Moss off
there you got to brush it off because
even if you treat it it's still there's
so much organic material up there that
the monster is gonna have a really easy
time just regrowing once you get rid of
it it's gonna be so much easier to treat
the Riff keep it from coming back
I'll use a stiffer nylon brush we really
want to be careful when we're brushing
if you brush too hard you can definitely
damage the shingles but if you're doing
it the right way you're doing it gently
you can just get rid of that Moss like
by just gently kind of flicking it off
you can Leaf blow it off later
so every roof is different it really
depends on how established the Moss is
how much Moss what type of moss if
there's a lot of trees that really
affects the amount of pressure that I
use when I'm brushing It Off
here I'm using a stick because the Moss
is so growing in that the brush can't
even really get in between the cracks
but I'll generally alternate you know
between the stick and the brush
depending on the Moss level depending on
what gets it off the quickest
I'll follow the leaf blowing with
another hand brushing and this will get
everything else that the leaf blower
didn't take care of it'll get it loose
and we can blow it off later
once all the Moss is gone and the roof
is clean we can begin the treatment
process when you're treating a roof our
main purpose is to raise the alkalinity
so raise the ph and you can do that with
laundry detergent you can do that with
the Zinc powder and also baking soda you
could use sodium hypochlorite which is
that's like bleach and with the
treatment it's usually a combination of
different chemicals that I use that
raises the ph and then makes it really
hard for the Moss to get established and
come back in the future
when you see me spraying up there that's
usually the sodium hypochloride
basically bleach killing everything up
there and then the Moss preventative
powder when I apply the treatment powder
Up on the Roof I really want to be
hitting the Peaks really hard because
that's gonna you know it's gonna flow
down the roof eventually Ledges gaps
seams placed around the windows as well
you want to put a little bit extra
sometimes down there
the size of the roof really determines
the amount of powder and treatment I'm
gonna need to put up on the roof when
you put the treatment powder on you can
leave it on there you don't really need
to touch it the rain is going to take
care of the rest for you it's going to
wash down over the next couple weeks
most cleanings that I do are roofs that
are at least five ten years old because
Moss is so damaging I always recommend
homeowners get their roofs clean and
treated every year to uphold the
integrity and longevity of the roof
[Music]